Ceri isn't it beautiful out today
interesting question
Johanna I don't really think it's that
interesting of a question anyway what do
you want to do today I rather enjoy what
I'm doing right now
me too let's get some food are you
hungry
okay check it out Siri get us an uber
what type of ride do you want
uberx
uber can get you a new Burks in four
minutes do you want to request it yes
your Hoover driver will be there in four
minutes
awesome Siri Thanks hi how are you
what's on my calendar for the rest of
the day okay here's your appointment
tell Jeff on whatsapp that I'll be 15
minutes late to the meeting which one
ready to send it yes send its sent hey
Siri how many calories in pizza anyway
let me check that the answer is about
384 dietary calories oh well what do you
thing about the election I'm afraid I
can't answer that all right what do you
think about the summer being over I'm
sorry
Joanna I'm afraid I can't answer that no
pot huh so good talk they're series you
need to rest up I'm afraid I can't
answer that
nice Siri send an email to Hanna what's
the subject of your email new best
friend what would you like your email to
say I found a new BFF she even works on
my Mac now are you ready to send it yes
ok Joanna I'll send it Siri why aren't
you always listening on my Mac I mean
having to press your icon or hold
command and space is annoying when
you're trying to do something else at
your desk is that what you think
when's the next train coming I found
this on the web for when is the next
train coming yeah that's the least
helpful thing ever Siri let's try again
Siri show transit directions home
getting transit directions to home
that's more like it
someone needs to work on their natural
language processing skills okay okay
game time Siri who is running for
president here's what I found on the web
for in time Siri who is running for
president
Alexa who's running for president the
Democratic Party's nominee for president
is Hillary Clinton the Republican
Party's nominee is Donald Trump the
Green Party's nominee all right Alexa
LexA we got it we got it
Siri your new features are good but
Amazon's Alexa is more convenient at
times and doesn't search the web as much
for answers do you have any feelings
about that let me feel nope nothing